c'est l'esprit start-up se retrouver
autour d'une partie de baby foot ou de
tennis de table se détendre tout en
faisant des rencontres pour le business
le principe de l'association french tech
paris saclay dans une démarche ou aux
caisses et ambiance sympa mais on
échange et cartes de visite trouver
quelque chose
quelques points communs cette
association veut rassembler les quelques
400 start up du territoire du plateau de
saclay jusqu'à versailles satory en
passant par saint quentin en yvelines
à paris ça qu'il ya une particularité et
c'est c'est une constitution deux tiers
de ce qu'on appelle le startup deep tech
donc qui portent des sujets en rupture
souvent issus des milieux académiques ou
la recherche publique lancée le 4
juillet 2019 french tech paris saclay
cherche à attirer des adhérents et des
futurs partenaires c'est un label qui
est reconnue désormais même à
l'international et donc c'est important
pour nous de faire partie de cette
communauté et ceux de tout ce réseau de
professionnels
la clé du développement économique c'est
la rapidité l'agilité une start up est
par définition très agile par contre
elle est souvent un peu isolé et donc il
lui faut du réseau pour toucher les
grands groupes
il faut pouvoir être plus visibles et
avoir une association telle que la prône
steak et avec des parents qu'ils soient
des grands industriels du cac 40
c'est un excellent moyen après le
plateau de saclay le vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
prochaine soirée sera organisée à
versailles